hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein ganz
besonderes video wir machen nicht nur
ein ultra leckeres rezept nämlich eine
tiramisu torte sondern es gibt auch noch
was zu gewinnen
deshalb bleibt unbedingt bis zum schluss
dran ich zeige euch jetzt aber
zuallererst mal die zutaten für unsere
leckere kredit und dies heute auch
besonders denn ich verwende heute
gelatine
da war auch der wunsch ganz groß dass
ich mal cremes mit gelatine zeige und
das mache ich heute und wir starten das
rezept mit folgenden zutaten schlagsahne
mascarpone creme fraiche außerdem seine
fest hier habe ich relativ keine sorge
die ist auch hella außerdem vanille
extrakt zucker löffelbiskuits und kalt
gewonnen ist ressort und ich habe das
jetzt immer oft gelesen viele sind
wirklich abgeneigt cremes mit gelatine
zuzubereiten dabei ist es gar nicht so
schwer
man muss halt nur einige sachen beachten
aber die zeige ich euch jetzt sie nehmen
sie zuallererst die gelatine blätter und
weichen die in kaltem leitungswasser 1
dafür gebe ich dir einfach eins sind
rein und dann warten der fünf minuten
aber wir nutzen jetzt die fünf minuten
zwischen zeit und geben unsere
mascarpone zusammen mit creme fraiche
zucker und vanille extrakt in eine
schüssel und verrühren das und falls ihr
euch fragt nur die sahne ist die habe
ich zurück in den kühlschrank gegeben
weil die muss richtig schön kalt sein
[Musik]
die mascarpone mischung ist fertig die
bleibt doch erst mal hier an der seite
wir kümmern uns jetzt um die gelatine
die ist in der zwischenzeit nämlich
schön eingeweicht das zeige ich euch
jetzt mal so sieht sie jetzt aus und ich
mach das mal so dass sich bewusst noch
ein bisschen wasser mit in den topf
geben den wir verwenden sagt ist ein
bisschen einfacher und jetzt muss das
ganze erhitzt werden ganz wichtig auf
langsame stufe bloß nicht kochen sonst
verliert die lehrkraft und dann
funktioniert leider nicht mehr
und das erhitzen der maschine das hat ja
wirklich nur ein paar sekunden gedauert
wichtig ist dass wir den herzlich auf
höchste stufe stellt sondern wirklich
die niedrige bis mittlere mehr auch
nicht und dann nochmal ein bis zwei
esslöffel vom wasser dazu gibt dann habt
ihr nicht jetzt einfacher denn jetzt
kommen wir zum temperaturausgleich das
ist auch sehr wichtig damit ihr keine
stückchen in eurer creme habt jetzt gebe
ich hier ein bis zwei esslöffel von
meiner mascarpone creme in den topf und
röders dabei ständig um
[Musik]
die stelle mit dem temperaturausgleich
ist auch sehr wichtig wie gesagt er
wollte keine klümpchen in der creme und
die bekommt eben diesen
temperaturausgleich nicht macht denn die
gelatine masse ist er erhitzt worden das
heißt sie ist warm und die mascarpone
ist bestenfalls auf zimmertemperatur
also ist die temperatur nicht gleich das
habe ich jetzt erledigt ich habe
insgesamt fünf bis sechs esslöffel der
creme hier eine tan ich mach lieber ein
bisschen mehr rein als zu wenig und
jetzt geben wir den inhalt vom topf
zurück in die creme und grüne gut um
[Musik]
das ist ja heute in den märkten gehören
heute ist echt wie der stunde am besten
durch die rektoren college block und
einen kugelschreiber mit für das video
das stimmt der lehrer der die tafel
geputzt und haben sogar so lange dass
sie immer bei mir am heft abschreiben
musste wie kommt man raus heute so die
creme kommt jetzt ganz kurz an die seite
wie widmen und jetzt nämlich die
schlagsahne die habe ich jetzt aus dem
kühlschrank genommen
wichtig ist und das predige ich auch
immer wieder dass die schlagsahne kalt
ist ganz frisch aus dem kühlschrank
kommt also und das eure schiffe jetzt
nicht unbedingt aus der waschmaschine
kommt das heißt dass die nicht wissen
also ihr könnt auch in die waschmaschine
tun aber ich würde es nicht dass ich
würde es nicht raten genau alles schön
kalt und nicht schlagen über die sahne
[Musik]
so die sahne habe ich jetzt 30 sekunden
angeschlagen
ich gebe jetzt seine fest dazu obwohl
wir die latina verwenden das ist einfach
persönliche präferenz ich finde dann ist
man einfach auf den sicheren seite und
hat noch mal schöne fest auf geschlagene
sahne und natürlich kommt die sahne
gleich noch zur latin american bank hat
das ganze ist mit dem handbuch fester
stoffe gedauert und der küchenmaschine
geht es ein bisschen schneller ist
übrigens aufgefallen hat sich heute
extrem ein handtor verwendet habt ich
habe euch nämlich dass man auf instagram
gefragt wie ihr lieber backt mit
handbohrer mit küchenmaschine oder haben
sie vielleicht keines von beiden da dann
schreibst du doch gerne mal hier auf
youtube jetzt nochmal in die kommentare
ich richte mich ja immer sehr gerne nach
euch und kreieren rezepte mit den sachen
die ihr zuhause habt so und jetzt kommen
wir zurück zur creme ich gebe jetzt in
zwei schritten die sahne mit in diese
linie mascarpone masse und das ganze am
besten mit dem teig shopper und mein
schneebesen kommt es an die seite mit
dem tisch aber funktioniert das nämlich
am besten
[Musik]
sobald ihr die sahne ganz vorsichtig mit
dem teig schaber untergehoben habt ist
die creme auch schon fertig und wir
können endlich schichten ich habe jetzt
hier nochmal einen saftigen schoko boden
gebacken den durch zwei geteilt ich
werde euch auch die angaben zu den
zutaten nochmal die infobox schreiben
und die größe ich habe mich nämlich
heute für eine 22 cm durchmesser torte
entschieden
ich will sie lieber ein bisschen kleiner
aber dafür ein bisschen höher und ich
nehme ihm einen sack kriegen gibt den
einmal um den boden in den zweiten boden
habe ich noch an der seite der kommt
gleich erst zum einsatz
und weil es eben ein tiramisu torte ist
habe ich meinen schoko boden nur durch
zwei geteilt ist ich habe nur zwei
showbühnen aber wir tricksen ein
bisschen denn der boden in der mitte der
besteht aus den am anfang erwähnten
löffelbiskuits und das was wir jetzt
machen ist folgendes ergeben die hälfte
der creme auf den boden geben dann die
im kaffee getrunken löffelbiskuits drauf
und dann nochmal die restliche creme
jetzt sind die löffelbiskuits dran und
ich teile die noch mal so mit den händen
durch drei das sieht im tanzschritt
einfach ein bisschen kohle aus für mich
kommt der außer kaffee nichts infrage
aber ihr könnt natürlich auch falls
kinder mit essen möchten auch kakao
nehmen ist auch ganz lecker oder noch
ein level weiter in dem milch und butter
spekulatius gewürzen oder zins auch sehr
lecker und ich habe mal die drei
sekunden regel drei sekunden tun und
dann drauf tun so die löffelbiskuits
creme ist jetzt fertig und jetzt kommt
die restliche kinderkrippe und wird
gestrichen
[Musik]
so alles glatt verstreichen und jetzt
kommt der schoko boden oben drauf dann
denken wir dass ab und kühlen das ganze
[Musik]
so der deckel ist drauf jetzt gebe ich
noch einen teller darüber damit der
deckel oben auch nicht austrocknet und
ihr jetzt gilt die faustregel für diese
torte mindestens drei stunden kühlen
damit die creme beige integrieren kann
und schön fest werden kann oder wenn sie
so ein bisschen aus organisatorischen
gründen sagt ich mache lieber morgen
weiter dann auch sehr gerne über nacht
so wie ich und dann sehen wir uns morgen
wieder die torte durfte jetzt eine nacht
lang durch kühlen es reichen aber wie
gesagt auch drei stunden und ich sag ich
doch mal die zutaten für unsere deko
bevor wir die torte aus den tortenring
befreien
wir benötigen kalte schlagsahne seine
feste außerdem vanille extrakt diese
süßen mutter wohnen hier und etwas bacau
jetzt werden wir erst mal den rand der
torte lösen und dann ziehe ich den
tortenring ab
[Musik]
und ihr seht die creme ist richtig schön
fest geworden und für die deko habe ich
mir gedacht bei denen tiramisu torte ist
soll es auch von oben also von außen so
aussehen wie tiramisu deshalb werde ich
die sahne jetzt aufschlagen und dann mit
meinem spritzbeutel mit einer loch tolle
einfach so tropfen artig obendrauf
spritzen
[Musik]
also ich hab die sanierte einen
spritzbeutel geführt meine lochten
durchmesser von neun millimeter falls
ihr das genauso machen möchte und ich
habe die sahne mit vanille extrakt
aromatisiert das fand ich jetzt einfach
ein bisschen leckerer als einfach mit
stinknormalen zucker und jetzt zu
spritzen wir einfach die tupfer auf ich
gehe dabei von innen nach außen und
versuchte dann so gleichmäßig wie
möglich auf zu spritzen
[Musik]
so die tupfer sind jetzt auf der torte
und wie beim echten tiramisu kommt hier
jetzt noch cacau drüber ich persönlich
bevorzuge wirklich back cacau viele
werden sich fragen kann ich auch ganz
normalen körper also trinkt account
könnt ihr natürlich auch ist ein
bisschen heller und ein bisschen süße
ist einfach nur so persönliche
geschmackssache so und das ging jetzt
durch ein sieb auf die torte
[Musik]
so und zum krönenden abschluss kommen
jetzt meine mutter wohnt zum einsatz ich
liebe die total ihr dürft mir die ganzen
herren gehe ich erst wie sonst einfach
so aber ich finde es mal gut weil das
ist so ein hinweis dass in der torte
café steckt also gehe ich jetzt einfach
so unregelmäßig auf die oberfläche
[Musik]
und die tiramisu torte ist fertig das
tolle ist wir müssen sie jetzt nicht
extra nochmal kühlen die kühe zeit haben
wir hinter uns wir können sofort
anschneiden und sofort servieren die
torte hält sich so im kühlschrank drei
bis vier tage ich garantiere euch
solange sie nicht halten weil ihr die
feuer komplett vernaschen werdet das
garantiere ich euch man sieht jetzt hier
schon von außen die einzelnen schichten
hier den saftigen schoko boden und damit
die leckere creme schicht und mein
highlight diese löffelbiskuits schicht
mit kaffeegetränk und obendrüber
natürlich die optik die mich total an
tiramisu erinnert so ich schreibe euch
die genauen zutaten und mengenangaben
wie immer und mir die infobox ich freue
mich sehr wenn ihr das rezept nach mache
ich freue mich über eure tollen fotos
mit dem hashtag s kitchen auf instagram
vergisst nicht meinen kanal hier
kostenlos zu abonnieren
und ganz wichtig die glocke aktivieren
denn sonst bekommt ihr leider nicht nur
mit welchen neues video hochladen und
für das gewinnspiel das jetzt einfach
dran
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt das gewinnspiel
natürlich möchtet ihr wissen was es zu
gewinnen gibt und ich zeige euch hier
mal das riesenpaket was ruft mir zur
verfügung stellt das ganze fünf mal aber
jetzt können wir erstmal zu den
produkten wir haben back trend spray
außerdem mit case in pink zweimal
zweimal in grün
unser berühmt ist beim wille extrakt wir
haben wir vier verschiedene sorten
porridge mein persönlicher favorit in
bayreuth trug total lecker heute noch
zum frühstück gab ausserdem creme wunder
rote früchte geschmack torten klassische
familie dann haben wir zwei malaga tine
chocolate chance achtung suchtgefahr
zweimal tonka zucker mandl krokant und
hier was ganz besonderes nämlich
feenstaub in silber und wir am anfang
schon erwähnt darf ich gleich fünf
dieser pakete verlosen ich packe hier
schon 30 1
ihr könnt auch ganz easy mitmachen es
gibt nur drei regeln zu beachten erstens
seit abonnent meines kann also seid ihr
am besten falle schon zwei like dieses
video und drittens schreibt mir einen
kommentar hier unten ins kommentarfeld
welches der gezeigten produkte euch
jetzt am meisten interessiert worauf
freut ihr euch am meisten mein highlight
von beruf ist ja dass vanille extrakt
zum auf- und zumachen ich liebe das
und ich freue mich wenn ihr zahlreich
mit macht auf grund der datenschutz
grund verordnung muss ich noch einmal
ganz kurz den hinweis geben eure
adressdaten werden anrufe weitergeleitet
eben für den postversand das ist nur
noch eine kleine rand info aber
definitiv werde ich alle genauen infos
und in der infobox schreiben also schaut
da auf jeden fall rein und nächsten
sonntag in sieben tagen wir dann
ausgelost und ich freue mich schon also
bis bald